SPEAKER: Please join me
in welcoming Mr. Shankar
Mahadevan.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
You did brave the Bay Area
traffic and did get in here.
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN:
Yes, it's fine.
Nothing to beat
the Mumbai traffic.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: But Shankar, let
me begin by welcoming you
in my mother tongue,
something which
you will be very familiar--
[NON-ENGLISH]
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN:
[NON-ENGLISH] to all the people.
[NON-ENGLISH], good afternoon.
SPEAKER: I should have guessed
you can't speak in most
languages now from India.
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN: Well,
[? I don't ?] [? speak. ?] I
actually sing.
Singing is easier.
SPEAKER: Easier-- actually,
that's a good beginning.
You are a regular
to the Bay Area,
but this time you are
here for a special cause.
Tell us a little bit
more about AIM for Seva
and your purpose of this visit.
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN:
Well, normally when
we come to the United
States, we come and perform
Bollywood music,
which is the most,
I think, popular form
of music which is there.
But this time,
it's really special
when I met the people who are
involved with AIM for Seva.
And I met [? Shrini, ?]
[? Shrini ?] and his entire
team.
And I went through
Swami [INAUDIBLE]
preachings, his speeches.
And I think the kind of
work that they are doing
is phenomenal.
I think [? Shrini ?]
will be explaining later
about what exactly, in detail.
But the kind of work that
they're doing is with children.
They take children right from a
very, very low economic strata
in life.
And they take them
all the way, give them
education, give them
a residence, I mean,
make their future actually.
So I wanted to bring this show
called "Krishna Sabrang," which
is music of our
country, India, through
our beloved lord Krishna.
Because Krishna is omnipresent
all over the country.
And when he's omnipresent,
there are so many cultures,
so many languages, so many
genres of music in India.
So if I can feature
all those in one
show and having a
common theme of Krishna.
So somehow [INAUDIBLE]
and Krishna Sabrang,
it was almost like doing
musical [? seva. ?]
And coming to the US and singing
popular music, film music,
is a no-brainer, actually.
I wanted the people
over here to also listen
to other forms of music, which
are there in our country, which
is like classical
music, [INAUDIBLE]
and all kinds of stuff.
So we put the show together.
And I'm very excited that
both my sons are there.
They're singing with me,
Siddharth and Shivam.
And we have the wonderful
[? Ankita ?] [? Juji, ?] who is
[INAUDIBLE] senior disciple.
And it's a very
interesting show.
And I hope that people enjoy it.
They've been enjoying
our tour all as well.
And I'm sure that they're
going to enjoy it here too.
SPEAKER: In fact, three
lucky Googlers today
are submitting raffles.
So hopefully they will have
a lucky entrance to the show
later.
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN: But
what an honor coming here.
I mean--
SPEAKER: An honor is ours.
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN:
Thank you, people.
Thank you for
getting us over here.
It's really--
[APPLAUSE]
It's like visiting
a friend, Google.
Because I think
sometimes one or two days
you don't meet your family.
But there's not a single
day when you don't
visit with Google, is there?
[LAUGHTER]
So it's like coming to
your best friend's house,
and to a place where
you come in, you
realize that this is the place
that's changed the world.
So thank you, thank you
once again, thank you.
SPEAKER: I'd love to get a
little bit more about, you--
and I spoke about
this during lunch--
about music being a passion
versus a profession.
Your introduction to music
happened at a very young age.
At the age of five, you
learned to play instruments.
You've had a very strong
grounding in classical music
before you ventured out,
explored many other areas.
Tell us a bit more about
why is music so important?
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN: Oh,
my god, I think just
to be able to appreciate
music, and enjoy music,
is, I think, one of the greatest
blessings that you can have.
And above that, if you are in
a position to perform music,
and if you're in a position
to entertain people
through your medium--
I think the whole idea of
music is communication.
It's a great form
of communication.
And I think you can
make people laugh.
You can make them cry.
You can make them feel inspired.
You can just make a person
who is probably the biggest
director in a company
just get up on the seat,
and dance, and just forget
about himself, and let go.
And that is the power of music.
And if you possess
that power, I think
God blesses you with that.
Very few people get the
blessing that, hey, you
are born to entertain people.
So you can communicate and
give joy, and enjoy something
that we take for granted.
If you're able to
give joy to somebody,
I think that is the greatest
blessing that you have.
And I think we
musicians, every day
we thank God, that, thank
God I am a musician.
And I'm able to give
happiness to people,
which is something which I
believe in very strongly.
I was an engineer.
I am an engineer, I can say.
I did my engineering from--
a lot of my engineering
classmates are here this area.
I mean, San Jose, Palo
Alto, maybe even in Fremont.
In fact, tomorrow I'm
having a breakfast
meeting with all my
engineering buddies.
And I did my engineering.
Though it was fantastic,
and it prepared
me to do a lot of stuff in
life, music was my passion.
It was deep within me.
And constantly I
had this feeling
that I'm here in this
planet to communicate music
to the people.
It used to always come to me
again and again and again.
And of course, then, you're
moving at a great pace.
You're with your friends.
And you're doing your
schooling, engineering.
You finish your course and
looking for a [INAUDIBLE]
interview, all that.
All that is happening.
But at some stage
you have to stop back
and kind of do a little bit
of internal thinking, and say,
hey, is this what
you want to do?
Or you want to--
there may be like millions
of other engineers
who are 10,000 times
better than you.
Do you want to do something
that you really want to do?
And there were people around me.
My wife, Sangeeta, is here.
I was going around with her
at that time, in my college.
And these are the people
who really stood by me
and said that--
And she did a very important
statement she made,
which really changed
things around.
She said that there may
be a million engineers.
But I feel that there will be
only one Shankar Mahadevan.
She said that.
[APPLAUSE]
And I don't know how much
of that is true, but--
[LAUGHS]
SPEAKER: You're
definitely somebody
whose voice is recognized not
only in the hearts of people,
but you're not only
popularized in India,
but you exist in our hearts.
So the statement--
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN: Thank
you, God is more than kind.
SPEAKER: A question
actually coming
in from a Googler
and a YouTuber.
We are all about--
we are in a generation
where things go viral.
We're all about trying to make
things as popular as we are.
Facebook is about trying to get
as many thousand likes, million
likes.
Your music, "Breathless," is
one of the most viral videos
on YouTube.
Tell us a little bit
about music going viral.
Is there a science to
making music going viral?
How do you?
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN: If that
would have been there,
there was a formula.
We always think, we
should have a formula
when we are creating the song.
While creating there should be
a red light or a green light.
So when you're creating, ding!
The green light goes, oh, this
song is going to be a hit.
If that would have
been possible,
we would have been
rich and famous.
You know what I mean?
There's no formula to that.
You have to-- see,
that is the risk
that you take when you
create path-breaking stuff.
I mean, I'm just saying path
breaking because path breaking,
meaning something
that doesn't exist.
You always want to
go beyond barriers.
You want to go beyond what you
have done, a benchmark that you
have created for yourself.
So when you're
trying to do that,
that is as risky as anything.
Either it can be
super successful,
or you can just fall
flat on your face.
So there is no formula
to doing a viral video.
Because if you try to use
a formula, which means
a formula is something
that already exists.
And you will always
be number two.
You'll be always compared to--
if I made another "Breathless,"
they will always compare that
to-- oh, at least 50% of the
people over here will say,
[INAUDIBLE],, this
is not like that.
Well, the first one,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
This is all very
good, but that one?
So you'll never, you'll
never reach that thing.
So I think the
only way you can do
it is try to create
something that doesn't exist.
I'm talking musically.
I don't know anything else.
So musically, try
to create stuff
that doesn't exist, try to
break your own benchmark,
try to create new
forms, new sounds, new,
something that even people may
not digest at the beginning.
When "Breathless" came out
so many videos were playing.
The indie pop thing was in.
The only thing I wanted was,
within the first five seconds,
your reaction should be,
what is this guy doing?
That's all.
If you got that emotion,
that's more than enough.
Then you, at least
you can capture
the curiosity of people.
And I think you have to do it
passionately and do it full on.
And maybe then, your song,
your video, your piece of music
may get viral.
But there's no formula to it.
I don't think so.
You all know better.
What are you asking me?
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: We thought we might
learn something from you.
Actually asking
you a question, you
have been a part of one of the
most successful musical trios
that India has seen
with Ehsaan and Loy.
Tell us a little
bit more about that,
because it's an industry
where styles of music
can be so variable.
Egos are fragile.
How did you form
that partnership?
And what made it so successful?
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN:
This is actually
a very interesting partnership.
And we, ourselves, are
very amazed at the way
we have sustained, because
we have completed 21
years of composing this year.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
[APPLAUSE]
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN: We
started off 21 years back.
And we three are completely
different individuals,
characteristics-wise and
musical preferences-wise,
temperament-wise,
choices, whatever.
The way we are, we are
three different individuals.
We have nothing in common.
But that is the beauty.
When you look at
a piece of music,
it's like a melody is created.
And you're looking
at that melody
from three different angles,
using three different cameras.
So what I see, he doesn't see.
And what he sees,
he doesn't see.
So it's three angles to
the same piece of music.
And we interpret it our own way.
And we don't use the
conventional, tried and tested
kind of stuff.
I'll give us one example.
I'd like to bring
Soumil, my nephew to--
It's OK if I sing
a few lines, huh?
SPEAKER: Oh yeah, I think so.
[APPLAUSE]
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN: I
think, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[LAUGHTER]
Can we have a
little more of my--
where is this, it's all over.
Is it the speakers?
Can you turn me up slightly
for the singing part?
SPEAKER: If you step forward
you might hear yourself better.
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN: Oh, is it?
OK, then it's fine.
OK, I trust you.
SPEAKER: Sorry.
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN: So
like we did this song
for one of our first films.
Not the first film,
called "Dil Chahta Hai."
Have you all seen
"Dil Chahta Hai"?
[APPLAUSE]
So the creation of the music for
this film was very interesting.
We planned out of 10 days
[INAUDIBLE] to Kandla,
where Ritesh Sidhwani,
the director, he
had a bungalow there.
And we wanted to stay 10 days
and create music over there.
So Ehsaan, Loy, me, [INAUDIBLE]
all of us, we drove to Kandla.
And we finished the
compositions, with the lyrics,
in three and a half days.
The entire score was over.
And we didn't know what to
do, and are in Kandla for--
we have another six days.
We chilled out for a day
and we just came back home.
So the music of "Dil
Chahta Hai" was created in
like over three and a half--
I mean, of course the
composition, not the recording.
So the first thing
that came about
was a bass line, which goes--
[PIANO PLAYING]
[SNAPPING]
So this was the
bass line that came.
And this was not supposed to
be the situation for the "Dil
Chahta Hai" title song at all.
It was just a bass
line that came.
And we wanted to use this song
for the Johnny Q [NON-ENGLISH]..
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
This song.
But then I was having a shower.
And suddenly this bass
line just, just play again.
[PIANO PLAYING]
So these four
notes, it just fits
into the title of the film.
So I just literally came
out running and said--
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
So what triggers what?
It's a crazy in music.
So this bass line said, oh,
my god, these four syllables
come in as the title
song of "Dil Chahta Hai."
So I just came in and said,
can we fit in "Dil Chahta Hai"?
And [INAUDIBLE] readily agreed.
And then of course he wrote
the song around the thing.
And we have many such instances.
So this trial is very exciting
because we respect each other
as individuals,
even after 21 years.
No egos, I think the ego is the
worst thing for a team to have.
I think, you all know better.
For a team to exist, coexist
for a long period of time, ego
is something that you
just leave in your house.
Because at the end
of the day, you're
playing with an abstract medium.
My melody, your melody,
his melody, everything
is valid because
we're all musicians.
And what I say is also right.
What you say is also right.
What she says is also right.
But I think eventually you
have to come to a consensus
based on what the
melody is telling you.
It gives out a feeling.
It gives out a
feeling in that room
that, yes, this is the melody.
And we will go with it.
And when you respect
that, I think
then everything falls in place.
And your music, I think it
will work for your music
more than anything else.
SPEAKER: Are there any
more interesting stories
with [? yourselves ?]
and more music for us?
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN: Oh yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
So many, I mean.
We were in [INAUDIBLE].
We'd set up our instruments
in this Taj [? Hotel ?] called
[INAUDIBLE].
And we were working on
the music for a film.
Loy, and the director
of film, and we were all
sitting and having breakfast
in one German bakery,
early morning, 7 o'clock.
People ask, where do you
get these melodies from?
How does it happen?
How do you get this, how
do you get these tunes?
Trust me, that's
what I'm saying.
I mean, really, if
you say that you
are in control of
your music, I think
that is the biggest false
statement that you're making.
Because you really don't know
where this music comes from.
That is what they say.
It is really divinity.
So then suddenly this tune
started ringing in Loy's mind.
And we all ran to the
sitting room where
we had set up our instruments.
And play now.
[PIANO PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
That's Soumil Shringarpure.
Let's hear it for him.
[APPLAUSE]
[PIANO MUSIC CONTINUES]
How many of you know this song?
So let's all sing
together, come on.
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
Everybody.
Outstanding.
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[APPLAUSE]
I must say,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
I'm not joking,
really, outstanding.
SPEAKER: We've seen a
few talks at Google.
But we've never seen where
you could create a chorus out
of a bunch of engineers.
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN:
You know what?
[LAUGHTER]
I've realized one thing.
Probably if you make people
over here individually sing,
they probably may go
out of [? suit. ?]
They may wander into
their own scale.
But I realized one thing.
When people sing in
a group, it somehow,
it just becomes into
one [INAUDIBLE]..
I don't know how that is.
That is the magic of music.
SPEAKER: You know
Shankar, there's
something called humility too.
And I know you are
downplaying this.
But the fact that music
just occurs to you,
that when you sing, that people
just seem to fall in place,
there's something about you--
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN: Well, I
was pointing the mic at them.
So they were singing actually.
SPEAKER: But that talks so much
about you as a person, too.
I mean, we see you all the
time, [? to ?] the point
that we were saying.
We see personalities,
which are larger than life.
In movies, we see them
on screen all the time.
A little known fact about you
is, you've been an actor, too.
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN:
Oh one film, yeah.
SPEAKER: You host a music show
today, which actually leads me
to the next question,
you explained so well
that you followed your heart.
And you had your wife with
you to explain to you, saying
that there could be
a million engineers,
but there could be
one Shankar Mahadevan.
But tell us a little
bit about music
as a passion and a profession.
There are so many
people today who
are aspiring musicians,
who come out there,
and who perhaps look
at this as to how
do I make it into a profession.
What is your word
of advice for them?
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN:
Firstly, I think
there are two ways of doing it.
I would say that what is
it that you want to do?
What is your ultimate aim?
Do you want to just
become a popular singer,
and become a YouTube sensation,
or something like that?
Or do you want to study music?
And as a result of which,
your music can become popular.
So what is it that
you wanted to do?
Both are valid, actually.
Because the path that I
took was a difficult path.
Because I studied
Indian classical music.
My foundation, the grammar
of, the language of my music
is classical music,
Carnatic classical music
is what I studied.
And I used that as a medium, and
all other forms of music that I
do, whether I'm
doing film music,
whether I'm doing fusion music,
whether I'm doing popular
music, [INAUDIBLE] music, or
[INAUDIBLE] music in south
India--
they're all derivatives
of classical music,
is what I believe.
But the other way
is, I mean, you
can become a one hit wonder, or
maybe a two, three hit wonder.
And you still can make
the same amount of money.
You can still have the same
amount of hits on YouTube,
or social media, still
be flying first class,
and traveling, and doing
your shows and all.
But it's totally up to you.
So if you want to approach
the popular route,
you still can do that.
But one thing is, you'll always
be unsure of what you're doing.
You'll not be technically
proficient as to what
your song is all about, what
is the skill that you use.
Is it a C major, E minor,
D-- ah, I don't know.
[? You'll see. ?]
What beat it is,
what are the chords
that are playing behind?
Do you want to know that, or
you don't want to know that?
I mean, end goal
can be the same.
But how you want to approach
it, what kind of a musician,
in depth, do you want
depth in your music or no?
Is what you have to decide.
And I think, personally,
being a musician--
I mean, for example, if you
want to become a journalist,
if your language
is really good, you
can write a beautiful article.
And I believe in that.
So if your grammar of
the language of music
is very strong, you
are very confident.
And you know what you are doing.
You know your direction.
You know 100%.
Yes, I have gone a little flat.
I've gone a little sharp.
[INAUDIBLE] Everybody feels it
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],, you know?
But you don't realize.
When you learn you
understand, oh, I'm going off.
This chord is not working.
This chord is working.
This rhythm cycle I can do.
It's interesting.
So you become a
student of music.
And you remain a
student of music
for the rest of your
life, which I feel I am.
I am a student of music,
which I am going to remain
till the end of my life.
I'm learning all the time.
I think, [NON-ENGLISH]
That is, that is a fun.
It's like learning any art form.
And our classical music, Indian
classical music, is so great.
It's the greatest form of
music in the world, I feel.
If you learn that, you get
certain musical powers--
musical powers, which you can
use to fly in any form of music
that you want to do.
So I feel that it's better
you learn music properly,
understand music, do a
deep dive [? yeah. ?]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] do
a deep dive, no, why not?
Learn properly and
enjoy the whole process,
and be a student for the rest
of your life, is my advice.
SPEAKER: So Shankar, you
sing in so many styles.
You have learned music from
various parts of India.
What is the kind of music
that you love to listen to?
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN:
If you see my phone,
or if you see the kind of
music that I listen to,
it's very varied.
I tend to learn from
every form of music,
whether it is Carnatic classical
music, whether it is Hindustani
classical music, or
whether it is Pink Floyd,
or whether it is Ed
Sheeran, whatever.
I listen to every
single form of music.
And I think the best thing is
to take the positive aspect
of every form of music.
And if you're a composer, you
can use it to your advantage.
For example, "Breathless"
that you've listen to,
it's a classical [? raga. ?]
It's a [INAUDIBLE]..
It's a form of
improvisation that you do.
Can you give me--
[PIANO PLAYING]
So if you take the
[INAUDIBLE],, for example,
in the South Indian
style, Carnatic classical,
and there's
Hindustani classical,
there are two forms of music,
Carnatic and Hindustani The
notes are the same.
It's the way you deliver it is
the style in which you sing it.
So if you're singing
Carnatic classical it is--
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
There are seven notes
in this [? raga. ?]
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
So if you're singing
in the Carnatic style,
this is the way
that you sing it.
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
The same thing if you
do it in Hindustani.
The way you sing it, there's
a little more [INAUDIBLE],,
as in, a little more
[INAUDIBLE],, a little more,
what can I say, you dwell
on the notes a little more.
That's how Hindustani.
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
OK, so you see the
style difference.
And then there are--
[APPLAUSE]
Oh no, that's OK.
There are these notes--
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
So you can play
with these notes,
where you can-- if you're
a classical musician,
you can improvise, and you
can create various imageries
using these notes.
If you want to depict moving
forward, you can say--
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
You want to go a little forward.
Come back.
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
If you want to jump--
Jump back.
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
Jump back and forth.
So you can literally
visualize music.
If somebody tells you, OK,
here is this playground,
and go to the middle of the
playground and just go crazy.
Just run around with music,
with these notes of [INAUDIBLE]..
So this is how it'll be.
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[APPLAUSE]
So while going through
a process like this,
I just give a meter
to [INAUDIBLE]..
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
I just sort of
[? rewrite ?] on this.
And then he wrote--
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
And then it went on and on.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: We can go on.
[LAUGHS]
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN:
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you.
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN: Thank you.
See in Hindi, there is a saying.
I don't know whether you
know this kind of thing.
It's called
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
This is a song, which is
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] many years
back.
So nobody feels satisfied
until I sing this song.
SPEAKER: Sure.
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN: So
that's why I sang it.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Before I stand
between you and the music,
I have a couple of more
questions regarding
causes that you care
for, your proud for.
The last time you
visited Google,
you spoke about the
Shankar Mahadevan Academy.
Love to hear about where
is it, what are your aims,
what are your dreams for it?
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN: See, I feel
very insignificant while I
address an audience that is
working in Google, oh my god.
Because--
SPEAKER: It's like us
singing before you.
[LAUGHTER]
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN: Is that it?
Yeah.
But the whole idea
was to give back what
I have learned over the years.
And ideally, as I was
telling you earlier,
imparting people with the
power of music is great.
Not everybody need not
become the greatest singers
in this planet.
But I think just being
able to learn music,
just being able to enjoy music,
is a great, great feeling.
Initially I thought that just
like how other great maestros
have done, you don't
take a piece of land
and construct an
academy which can
teach Indian classical music.
But then that little
bit of engineering thing
that was there in me,
me and my partner, who
used to stay right here in Palo
Alto, [INAUDIBLE],, both of us,
we put this Academy together.
It's called the
shankarmahadevanacademy.com.
It's an online academy.
We started off with
about 15 students
because I did not see any other
academy of this nature, what
we had in mind.
So there was no reference point.
So we all did it, trial
and error, trial and error.
We formed the curriculum,
created online music books
called OM books.
We call them OM books.
So you can study
from those OM books,
plus there are online classes.
Everything that an
academy gives you,
a physical, brick and
mortar academy gives you,
we give it online,
except for the building.
And after six years, we are
teaching in 72 countries
right now, teaching
Indian classical music.
[APPLAUSE]
I hope that Google here
also tries to help us out,
till it becomes
bigger and bigger.
So--
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: It's number
one [INAUDIBLE]..
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN:
Yeah, I think you
go, Google search,
you go and search,
learn music online, Shankar
Mahadevan Academy, number one.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: You figured
out SEO all by yourself.
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN:
No, it's actually,
it's my partner, [INAUDIBLE].
He's also a technical kind
of wizard, kind of a guy.
And see, we as artists,
we dream a lot.
We want to do this.
We want to create this.
You want to-- but if there
are people with you who
take it to the next level,
and implement it, and make it
happen, that's when it
becomes a success story.
So [INAUDIBLE] is the
one who has really
made it a success story for me.
And it's so lovely that
when I go and meet--
every city I go, every
country I go, students--
for tomorrow's concert, I
think a whole lot of my academy
students are also going to
come, along with the [INAUDIBLE]
children.
And they're going to
sing [INAUDIBLE] with me.
So it's such a lovely feeling.
It's great.
SPEAKER: Actually it's
perfect time to actually bring
AIM for Seva back in here.
We would love to hear
more about the program.
Can I have the--
SRINI RAMAN: My
name is Srini Raman.
I'm the Chief Operating
Officer AIM for Seva.
But basically I'm also
a mechanical engineer--
from Detroit, helping in
the automotive industry,
but the automotive industry
now shifting to the West Coast.
And Google is going
to play a major role.
But I had a calling
two years ago
when [INAUDIBLE],, a
founder of AIM for Seva
gently touched my shoulder
and said, I need you.
To do want?
To lead AIM for Seva USA.
And my answer was
very spontaneous.
And I said, there are
a million engineers,
but there can be
somebody who can
play the role of
a small squirrel,
like how that helped
[? Sriama ?] build the bridge,
and the bridge of connecting
the people who don't have
and the people who have.
So I told myself [? if ?]
I can play that role,
and this is what
I feel satisfied
at the end of the day,
just like how Shankar said.
And he had the calling
to dedicate himself
for the music, I'm standing
in front of you dedicating my,
whatever little
skill that I have,
in bringing these
people together.
Because AIM for Seva is
a people's [INAUDIBLE]..
It is like [INAUDIBLE]
freedom movement, [INAUDIBLE]
had a vision of Seva
movement, what does it mean?
Each one of us, in
whatever way we can,
should care for the
people who don't have.
So having said
that, AIM for Seva
started when a [? tribal ?]
woman named [INAUDIBLE]
met Swamiji in 2000.
And she said her children
dropped out of the school.
Reason being, far away,
the home is far away
from school, and dysfunctional
home, and poverty.
So she gave an idea.
[? willing ?] to
start [INAUDIBLE],,
the hostel where
her children can
stay very close to an
existing government school.
And they stay until
they finish high school.
Swamji thought this is a
very pragmatic solution
for a very practical
problem that this woman has.
And that's how AIM for Seva
was founded in the year 2000.
And thanks to [INAUDIBLE],,
we have now over 100 hostels
across 16 states of India.
[APPLAUSE]
It's a small
beginning, we call it.
There are 600
districts in India.
So we need to build that.
There are 14,000 children that
have graduated high school.
And our success rate is 90%.
So the children stay with us.
And they stay for about
seven to 10 years.
And we take care of them
like our own children.
We give a house.
They give food.
They get school supplies.
We teach some values.
And we make sure that they
graduate from high school.
And if they are
doing well in school,
we take them to college.
And guess what?
Two students from a tiny
village in [INAUDIBLE]
finished college, and they
have a job offer at [INAUDIBLE]
Consultancy Services India.
[APPLAUSE]
This is all happening
in the 15 years.
We believe that every
child deserves education.
And let's hear from one of
the children, her life story.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[END PLAYBACK]
SPEAKER: Shankar, If I may
have you back on stage.
I would like to conclude
my part and get out
of the way between
Shankar and the magic.
We always say that it's
magical to witness genius
when it's combined with
passion and humility.
I think we got to see that
over the last one hour.
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN: OK, I can
just ask them a few requests.
Then I can sing for a
few lines of the songs
that they want to hear, simple.
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SPEAKER: Actually, we have
Shivam and Siddharth also.
So if I may invite
them on, please.
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] South
Indians.
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN: OK, two to
three lines of everything, OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN:
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
SHIVAM MAHADEVAN:
SHANKAR MAHADEVAN:
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[APPLAUSE]
Give me F. [NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
Thank you, thank you, thank you.